o que é ea aplicação de lei penal tanto
quanto vocês estão aqui em macapá
olha só eu cheguei no hotel eu deitei
aqui na cama eu fui tirar um cochilo
aí quando eu tava assim no meio do sono
assim tempo você está entre acordado e
dormindo eu me espantei eu lembrei que
quando eu tava dormindo e se quando era
criança me espantava minha mãe vinha e
cantava a música pra mim aí fazia dormir
joga pouco nunca entrei na vida foi
cantiga de ninar é dar uma espiadinha
começava a balançar a rede othon rede
balançando bem devagarzinho escutava sim
tô mining que a cuca vai chegar
papai foi pra rossi mamãe foi trabalhar
é ai rapaz foi para a roça mãe foi
trabalhar em casa não tem pregado quem é
que tá balançando a rede meu deus do céu
atividade paranormal fajece me abençoou
o meu deus é deus forte um grande el
shaday todo poderoso adona ainda que a
outra esse gatinho de cima do telhado
pra ver se essa criança dormir um sono
sossegado que gato em cima do telhado
sem saco máquina que com os três
é hora de fazer zoada gato a culpa vai
descobrir que aqui em casa por não
bastasse essa música vive com outra boi
boi bom não boi novo hobby boi da cara
preta preto do rock o papel medir boyle
é esse menino que tem medo de careta eu
brincar eu eu não tenho um hotel muito
careta eu a ver a segunda parte não não
não não o coitadinho ele tá chorando
porque ele é bonitinho então vocês
sabiam que eu ia chorar já estava
premeditado que sabe que chorar pra quem
cantou tá pra fazer do bié para dormir
vai para chorar é para dormir porque por
mim chorando tem como já viu do be
chorando o dinheiro bem a criança cresce
né claro a criança sempre cresce vai
criando essa amizade e aí e ter essa
música que dá barato a barata diz que
tem tem tem 7 sai de filó e nunca vi
nenhum assad filme tira da barata ela
tem é uma só
ela tem é ou é só apontando e diminuindo
a obra barata diz que tem uma cama a de
má-fé enfim a mentira da batida ela
tenha de cabeça
fd cap gente para um milhar barato desse
jeito a copa do mundo é realmente que
tem uma coisa não tem mais jeito milhar
pessoa foi assim que surgiram as
primeiras pessoas fofoqueiros menina que
ficou sabendo da barata bairro do outro
cão de marfim era desde capinha mas
saída cada obra barata me dá até um
pouco mas esta pena de tornam essa aqui
o ano é o que tu me testes era vidro e
se quebrou o amor que tu me tinhas era
pouco e se acabou foi assim que nasceram
as primeiras músicas de jorge mateus a
frança começa de criança do méxico em
setembro o amor que nunca pensei acabou
tudo bem bonito fica deve e vai embora
tem de crianças pessoas sofrem com
música de jorge mateus não sabe até aqui
ó
eu quero um bom humor do limão 1 quer um
pedaço e da menina mais bonita
eu quero nem
dê um abraço primeiro quem feijão é
maluco já que um gol da laranja metade
do limão é um golo do limão ea metade da
laranja gostoso mas não é esse porque eu
quero chegar não foi nessa música que
inventar o fan page a inocência de uma
criança já apresentava um facto que o
kaká vai ao show do cantor na casa do
caminho já que kaká já tá tá tá tá tá tá
tá tá tá tá tá tá i ta muito fez se
ouvir de hoje eu espero vocês tenham
gostado se você vai gostar de se mostrar
esse vídeo aqui no youtube sempre gostei
aqui no youtube volta lá no facebook de
acontece vídeo novo treinados e que é
você quem curte lá e marca seus amigos
nos comentários e olha que o verdadeiro
significado que perdeu a verdade
significa das cantigas de ninar olha aí
fulano de tal no twitter você dá rt que
a ajuda de mais quero ficar sem poder
das coisas clicando em inscrever se
neste canal toda vez que tivermos não se
sabe em valeu meu parceiro é nóis